so this you just have to see
to understand the complete and total
disconnect from reality that has
infected yeah infected the Republican
party when it comes to the coronavirus
pandemic Republican Senator Ron Johnson
appeared on Fox News over the weekend
and he was asked could you ever get a
vaccine behind get behind a vaccine
mandate we know you're not for one right
now but could you ever get behind the
government mandating that people get a
vaccine and Ron Johnson said I mean it's
completely Beyond parity he said I could
only do that I could only support a
vaccine mandate if there was a deadly
disease spreading now of course he means
more deadly than covid let's take a look
at the video and then discuss
you see that if you have this virus
and you spread the virus and you're
unvaccinated you have a chance of being
a better chance being hospitalized but I
don't think you can mandate someone get
vaccinated I'm pretty sure that we've
never done that before and it was a
month ago when both Kamala Harris and
the president said I can't force anyone
to do it but Europe is doing that could
you ever get behind a vaccine mandate
for everybody
no not unless there's some incredibly
deadly disease I mean much higher
infection fatality rates we have with
covert we don't know the final infection
fatality rate so he says he could only
get behind a vaccine mandate if there
was something really deadly spreading to
which he clearly is is referring uh uh
to something much deadlier than covet
and then he later on went on to say I'm
not downplaying covid but you know
something about the fatality rate of the
flu he said now let's let's break this
down in Parts this hopefully will be
useful uh to some of you dealing with
disinformation in your local communities
in your households even based on the
calls I got last week the flu case
fatality rate the CFR is about 0.1
percent
the covid case fatality rate is 3.1
percent that's 31 times higher 31 times
higher than the flu now you might say
wait David what do you mean 3.1 percent
I thought that the the death rate of
covid was only 0.8 percent remember
we've got different metrics here we're
talking about the case fatality rate
that is deaths divided by known cases
known cases because of the number of
unknown and never tested covid cases for
a variety of reasons it is believed that
the infection fatality rate is 0.8
percent but here we're comparing the
case fatality rate of flu and the case
fatality rate of covid 3.1 percent for
covid 0.1 percent for flu 31 times
higher okay
so that comparison is weird
um then you have
how infectious are they
r0 which is the or the r naught is a
measure of how infectious how easily
spreadable a condition is the r naught
for the flu is somewhere between one and
two
for covid the r naught was originally
believed to be somewhat higher without
taking any mitigation measures so
probably in the area of two to four and
the whole point of the mitigation
measures was try to get it below one so
it stops spreading and the Delta variant
is believed to be way more contagious
we're still learning but it could be
something like five to seven we're not
totally sure but the Delta variant is
dramatically more contagious so the flu
comparisons all would point to taking
covid really serious way more deadly and
way more contagious than the flu now of
course if you say well let's I want to
compare it to something like Ebola
something really deadly it is absolutely
true that Ebola is really deadly Ebola
kills the the death rate of Ebola really
varies depending on the medical
facilities that are available it's also
a much smaller sample size but ebola's
death rate is estimated
at 25 to 90 percent of those infected
the infection fatality rate of Ebola is
an average is about 50 percent now a big
portion of that is because of where
Ebola happens Ebola overwhelmingly takes
place in poorer countries where people
often end up dying of shock from fluid
loss that would likely be lower if Ebola
was only in a country like the United
States because of more advanced medicine
and access to more advanced medicine but
there's no doubt covid is way way less
deadly than Ebola but it's way more
contagious Ebola is transmitted by
bodily fluids and it has an R naught of
between one and a half and two and a
half covid and especially the Delta
variant are way more contagious than
Ebola because of how it spreads so the
point here is when someone like Ron
Johnson says oh you know I'd think about
a vaccine mandate if we had a really
serious deadly virus spreading what
exactly does he mean how deadly and how
contagious we have to be asking that
because when they say oh flu flew well
hold on a second let's figure that out
because you could have something that's
way more deadly but way less contagious
and you could have a similar
expected death toll because you're going
to have fewer infections because it
doesn't spread as easily with a higher
death rate and you could have the same
number or more people die my instinct is
everything I just said isn't even a
factor when someone like Ron Johnson
says this my guess is he'll say I would
look at a vaccine mandate if we had a
serious disease spreading and then he
would go to him and he would say okay
tell us exactly what an iMat what
disease combination of are not and death
rate would qualify as serious in your
mind and my instinct is he'll move on to
the next talking point I don't think
they actually really know what they're
saying they're just coming up with
something to not have to be in favor of
a vaccine mandate now and then if there
was a different situation he'd come up
with a different reason to oppose it
these guys are clueless is the point
that I'm trying to make